That's him saying he clicked on that
Reddit link. You should be [__]
ashamed. I love Beckett, but you should
be [__] ashamed. Truly. Beckett,
you're just in got you're just saying
things. You're just saying things. None
of it actually maps onto any real
distinctions. To pretend that you don't
know when you do is to lie. Yes? So, I I
spoke to Beckett last night, guys. I
spoke to Becky last night. I'm not going
to go over the whole Becky stream or
like all the relevant parts of Nick
stuff cuz it's a lot of effort. I can't
be bothered. But basically, TLDR, uh as
usually happens,
Beckett got flamed by faceless accounts
on Twitter and spoke out about it, as
always. So, he was arguing with these
these faceless accounts about something
that he doesn't want to get involved in,
guys.
So, that's what I do when I don't want
to get It's fine to argue with, you
know,
on Twitter if you like arguing.
But if you're saying you don't want to
get involved, why are you going 15
replies deep with room temperature
shrimp? Why Why are you doing that?
That doesn't seem like it's smart. But
Beckett gets on stream and he talks
about this more. And basically, in the
process of talking about this, he says
some really stupid things. Beckett says
two things that really set me off.
First, he says, uh we can't know for
sure what was struck
by Ethan, what the what was DMCA'd
struck by Ethan. We just have to trust
Paige. And he said Nick never covered
Paige's video. Those are two totally
incorrect, totally false statements.
Now, let's go over this quickly. So,
basically, January of 2025, Paige
Christie makes this video. She's laid
out to Nicholas DeOrio that these are
not just re-uploads of the podcast. They
are actually short clips taken from
non-members live streams. I should say
3-hour-plus podcasts, that's the main
show. And that the Reddit post linked
here has all the posts, has everything
laid out, all the evidence is there. So,
this is in January of 2025, and this
Reddit thread is taken down now, but it
was up at the time. You see here,
Nicholas DeOrio responds to this. He has
seen He's at least seen the link.
Maybe if you're like a desperate re
who will say anything to sweep, you can
pretend that he didn't click the link
and didn't read it at this point. Now, I
don't I don't have the letter to hand,
but fortunately, in the Denims lawsuit,
Ethan's lawyer does actually lay out the
DMCA takedowns that he issued. So,
August 1st, 2024 DMCA takedown. On
August 1st, 2024, TI issued a DMCA
takedown for the H snark post entitled
H3 live show behind the scenes.
Post contained a complete version of
TI's video H3 podcast behind the scenes
53, which was members-only content.
I.e., accessible only to paying members
of the H3 podcast YouTube channel. On
August 2nd, 2024, i.e., 1 day later,
rather honored DMCA takedown.
So, that seems that seems above board,
right? Members-only content fully ripped
and posted. Seems pretty above board.
Okay, next one.
August 30th, 2024. On August 30th, 2024,
TI issued a DMCA takedown for comment by
Don number three
uh on the H3 snark post entitled mega
thread of the H3 show August 28th, 2024.
The comment contained a YouTube link, so
that's um
to avoid ads to the TI video content
Jack Doherty H3 show 48. So, you can
maybe say a link to avoid ads, you can
DMCA. You can make You can maybe give
them that one. Now, September 18th,
2024. TI issued a DMCA takedown for the
H3 snark post entitled Ethan and Dan
confirm the posting to snark will get
you banned. The post solely comprised of
a clip from the TI video Ethan debates
anti-Semitic Sneako fan H3 show 55.
Remember, H3 show is the same as the
last one. That was a free show.
Remember, I as much as I say you can
maybe say avoiding ads is a fine thing
to strike, that's not really true, is
it? Because Ethan actually did open
their IP and say they weren't going to
enforce that stuff against anyone. They
actually did say they weren't going to
enforce any copyright against anyone on
the basis of their non-members public
shows. They said you can rip it,
re-upload it, profit from it, do
whatever you want with it. That's what
they said, very clearly. So, as much as
I'm giving charity there, I shouldn't.
So, yeah, then this one. So, this one
though, this third one, this is a clip.
Says there, a clip. Then here, November
22nd, H3 Show 83, post contained a clip
from the TEI video, We Play Poker with
Ninja and Practical Jokers and more. H3
Show 83. That is again, non-members.
Second takedown here, H3 Show 84, DMCA
takedown, and it's a clip. Again, they
say there, a clip. Uh November 26th,
2024, and we see takedown of a clip from
the TEI video entitled, I Haven't Been
Well, H3 Show 85. And then, takedown of
a clip from the TEI video entitled, I
Haven't Been Well, H3 Show 85. So, two
from the clip from the show titled, I
Haven't Been Well. So, basically, one of
these is above board. Clipped
members-only content in full, and they
took it down. That's reasonable. Second
one, on the Ethan standard,
unreasonable, cuz he's opened his IP.
That is unreasonable. So, any defense of
that is kind of [__] But, I'll give
some charity. Let's pretend for a moment
that's fine. All these three, and these
two, so that's five DMCAs. There are
five false DMCAs. Two arguably
legitimate DMCAs, five false DMCAs. H
informs Nick of this in January of 2025.
Nick is sent the Reddit post that
details it all. He says, "If he's
striking down posts that are here, watch
us mirror, don't give Ethan views." And
that's based on best practices. H says,
"No, he's not." I'd say that would be
fair also, but it's not what he's doing.
Now, like I say, for a total compromise
[__] who's desperate to sweep, you
might say that Nick didn't read the
thread here. So, here we see,
confirmed, Ethan Klein hired an attorney
to issue copyright claims against H3
shanks. This is what This is what Nick
gets sent. For detailed timeline of
events leading up to this announcement,
please see false copyright strike
tracker mega thread, Ethan Klein's
abusing the copyright system sensor
criticism of himself and the H3 podcast
on Reddit. 17th of December 2024 the H3
stock mods were sent evidence that an
attorney acting on behalf of Ted
Entertainment Inc been filing DMCA
takedowns against videos on the sub. The
OP whose post such clips removed by
Reddit legal operations team submitted
an intellectual property inquiry with
Reddit legal support and sent the
screenshots with PDF copy of Reddit's
response.
On January 25th, 2023 Ethan announced on
air that he was opening up the H3 IP to
the world after being inspired by Hasan
[__] and the HasanAbi Industrial
Complex. He was excited that clips from
non-members and members only content
could possibly help others gain some
financial stability and even give them a
chance to grow their own YouTube
channels. H3 talked about how excited
they were they opened up their IP on the
show more than once. Almost exactly a
year later Ethan made another
announcement on air via Instagram and
via Instagram stories he was going to
start DMCA-ing all members content. One
creators using members only clips that
they should remove those clips if they
don't want a strike against their
channel.
The video chapter in the episode is even
titled SYNT highlights
uh referring exclusively to members only
content. Ethan said he felt it was
unfair that content intended for paying
members was being shared by clip
channels for free. Ethan never publicly
announced that he was closing up his IP
or that he would strike clips of
publicly accessible non-members H3
content. How do you know it's Ethan
filing DMCA takedown notices and not
someone else? OP's email from Reddit
legal team confirms claims against clips
posted on H3 Snark have been filed by a
lawyer on behalf of Ted Entertainment
Inc TI. Ethan's the host of the H3
podcast show and the co-founder and CEO
of TI.
The lawyer acting on behalf of TI
previously represented Ethan Hila Klein
in other lawsuits they worked on their
landmark fair use case. A lawsuit that
brought the Kleins international
recognition and respect especially in
the YouTube commentary community. They
also worked on Triller Fight Club 2 LLC
versus H3 Podcast.
See a redacted copy of the PDF shared
with H3 Snark's mod team here. How this
all went down. Here's a timeline of the
events on the information we've been
able to gather so far. They They talk
about the strikes here. They talk about
why they're striking it. But basically,
this whole thing it links through to
everything.
It shows you which post removed. You
can, I believe, let's let's just have a
quick look. There's no snapshot for this
actual post. It says removed by Reddit's
legal operations team. But you can
pretty clearly interpret from the post
title here. It says Lone Wolf Box says
far left does hate Israel because
Israel's backed by the West. This can
lead to anti-Semitism. H 3 says freedom
of religion, speech, press to control
r/the_donald workspace will be under
state control in communism. H3 Show 85.
So, H3 Show 85, very clearly
non-members. Lone Wolf Box was on.
Clearly non-members.
Anyone
would probably remember this talk.
Obviously non-members. And just from the
format of the post, you can clearly
interpret that that is a clip. So, there
is really
not any room for doubt, to be honest,
even just from seeing the archived post.
Even without the clip there,
just look at the post. Pretty It's
pretty clear what's happening here. It's
pretty clear that it's a clip from a H3
Show episode. Non-members, obviously
that's what H3 Show is. They could know
that with Lone Wolf Box on, which it
would have happened recently. So,
there's there's no, you know, room for
doubt here, really. So, at that point
it's like confirmed. Like you you you
think that this massive subreddit is
going to get away with faking
responses from Reddit's legal operations
team when you know they're in contact
with the moderators. That's something
that they're in contact with the admins.
That's something Ethan cries about. It's
a fact that Sargon mentioned about being
in contact with admins and stuff like
that. Admins do reach out for these big
subreddits. That does happen.
Uh the idea that they're going to like
fake this legal notice from Reddit legal
operations team is pretty crazy. Uh and
you can just see from the posts that
what they're saying seems to line up
with all the publicly available
evidence. And what Ethan's saying does
not line up with any of the publicly
available evidence. So, that's just
That's a tertiary investigation, guys.
If you take a tertiary glance at this
link that Page Kristie said, immediately
it's like, "Okay.
Ethan Ethan probably isn't just striking
members-only content here. He's probably
not striking exclusively mirrors. That
does not seem to be what's happening
here whatsoever."
That's it. And that's just a tertiary
glance. And remember, guys, we're still
just in January of 2025 here. So, that's
in January of 2025. Nick, at that point,
really, when he's responding to this, to
anyone reasonable, he must either know
or be pretty certain that it's the case
Ethan wasn't just striking members-only
mirrors. That's crazy. That's crazy.
That's crazy. It's crazy to think that.
It's crazy. It's [__] crazy to think
that. But, guys, however, obviously
briefly looked at this yesterday. to
their families How did I What?
There's something
privileged lawsuits to Redditors, to
anonymous Redditors, knowing full well
that they would be scared into
submission. You also posted about that
on your Instagram stories By the way,
all right.
I think that's the basest part. Like,
that's the best part of this is that he
scared a bunch of Redditors into just
[__] themselves and shutting an
entire subreddit down.
Absolutely. Go look up Go type in on H3
Snark and go read what they wrote about
DiOrio, and tell me how much I should
feel bad for them that these little
[__] rat [__] had to sit and cry and
get scared for the night where they
thought the big mean Ethan Klein lawsuit
was going to be in the mail the next
day. I think that honestly I think that
it should be make make [__] make
um vocal unhinged fans scared again.
Should be like the 2025 motto. Holy
[__] I I I'm the the verdict is out on
whether I would defend these people. Uh
if Ethan went ahead and sued them, I
would need to see that on the actual
thing. But, holy [__] dude, do I think
they deserve to shudder in fear for a
night? That'd be very funny.
>> knowing full well that they would be
scared into submission. You also posted
about that on your Instagram stories as
well.
>> Can an anonymous Redditor what they're
sharing is paywalled content. The The
point that Ethan makes is that they were
posting stuff like, "Hey, don't give
this a So So, guys, a moment ago that
Hassan said lawsuits. He said suing
Redditors or something like that. So,
some people try to say that Nick is
talking about the lawsuits here, okay?
content. The You also posted about that
on your Instagram stories as Can an
anonymous Can an anonymous Redditor what
they're sharing is paywalled content.
The The point that Ethan makes is that
they were posting stuff like, "Hey,
don't give this a click on Ethan's
channel. Here's a reupload." And those
were the things he had DMCA'd.
Oh, no, he is talking about DMCA strikes
there, isn't he? That's why he uses the
word DMCA. So, it He understands what
Hassan and Ethan are referring to here.
He is not confused by the use of the
term lawsuit there, whatsoever. He knows
what's being referred to here.
That was That's his argument. But again,
I have not seen this stuff. I don't know
the nature of the lawsuit. The clips
aren't there. I don't know how long they
are. I can't make any pro So,
notice that, guys. Remember, this is in
May 2025.
The clips aren't there.
I don't know how long they are.
Okay?
Now, what do we know?
One,
Ethan has established that his
non-members content has open IP. He will
not enforce IP against anything of his
non-members content. So, to know that
they are false DMCA strikes, you
actually only need to know that they
were from non-members content, okay?
What As I've just shown, without the
clips being there,
the clips have titles that have the
exact wording in the clip that you could
search in the transcript,
and they are labeled with the number of
the show that they happened in. So, you
can go and very quickly see exactly what
is in those posts for some of them
without having to have the original clip
that's there. Now, will you know how
long the clip is? No.
But, you will know it's not members, and
you will as a result know that it's a
false DMCA from Ethan. That is all you
need.
So, Nick has got that information, guys.
At this point, Nick's saying
the clips aren't there, that's him
saying he clicked on that Reddit link.
He clicked on that Reddit link. He's
seen the timeline of posts. He's clicked
on the Reddit link, guys. Is he DMCA'd?
>> So, any argument that you're having
about the page Christy DM's and Nick not
seeing it, Nick Nick saying, "Oh, well,
I don't know. He said he was striking
stuff as members only, and maybe he just
didn't look at it. Maybe he shouldn't
look at it." No, he did look at it. He's
acknowledging that he's looked at it.
DMCA'd. That was that's his argument.
But again, I have not seen the stuff. I
don't know the nature of the lawsuit.
The clips aren't there. I don't know how
long they are. I can't make any pro or
against Ethan judgment until I have
>> You actually can. You actually purely on
the information you have at that point,
you actually can state that Ethan has
done multiple false DMCA strikes. You
actually can say that based on the
information you have at this point. Like
I just went over, you can go see this
post very clearly totally labeled. All
you need to know is it's from a free
show to know it's a false DMCA strike
because Ethan opened up his IP. This is
from a free show. It's from H3 Show 85,
and you can confirm that by going and
checking this in the transcript and
saying exactly where it's from.
It would be incredibly easy. It would be
trivial.
And he would see this when he goes on
here. He would obviously see this.
It that it's all even listed here. Look.
It it it literally says everything here.
It lays everything out. have more
context. defend you and harass you. Can
anonymous posters who Freedom of speech.
Dude, this is the best part. The best
part of being a free freedom of speech
enthusiast is that I'm not a freedom of
speech absolutist. Every freedom of
speech absolutist gets canceled because
they start debating [__] like child
porn or something on social media. Have
you noticed this? Everyone who calls
himself a free speech absolutist has
some weird CP conversation on social
media and then everyone stops calling
>> Genuine, if you remotely care about free
speech, hearing someone post [__] like
this, you should want to see this person
like, you know, face a face a
you know, jury of their peers, frankly.
Face a jury of their peers. It's like
you are so lost, man. You are so [__]
lost.
Just saying that anyone anyone that
gives a [__] about free speech enough to
defend against false DMCA's is a
pedophile. Is that's what he's saying
here. If you give a [__] about false
DMCA's
against
snark users, you're you're essentially a
pedophile. You're essentially a
pedophile. You have such insane beliefs.
You have such insane beliefs about free
speech. You would allow people to like
rape kids and post online. That's what
you'd allow. calling them. They just
stop going on shows. That That's the
only way that you could be a free speech
absolutist if you have a really bad take
on like child porn or something.
Um
>> [laughter]
>> Now, realistically, my principle says
that like I might not agree with this
lawsuit. My principle doesn't say I have
to defend people who've been completely
[__] slandering me. It just means I'd
abstain from the conversation if I don't
support it. That's where I would stand
on it.
Yeah, I don't know. I I think these
people deserve to sweat. My My just my
opinion.
Literally posted fake a doctored post.
I'll be like, "Oh, yeah, that's pretty
bad. I don't really agree with that."
And then I'll cover whatever else is on
the topic or the docket that day. You're
not
>> So, he's telling you right now
he would he is literally saying he would
do everything to avoid commenting on it.
And what's he doing while doing that?
Tailed to my support.
Posted it on her subreddit saying I was
banning people who are wishing a happy
Ramadan. Okay? And that went viral. know
what the deal was. I don't even know
what the [__] that was about.
>> an outright lie. Hold on, dude. Let me
respond.
Get your lawyer to try to bully and try
to
>> [laughter]
>> bully and try to bully and try to bully
and try to bully and try to bully and
try to bully and try to
Let me answer. Are you just going to
[__] get Okay, you want to make this
interview unwatchable? Is that your
goal?
I
Yeah, kind of, right? So, let me talk.
>> And by the way, just for example, all
right? It's not like And they post up H3
post and say, "There is a gap here,
guys. There is a gap here between the
uh
that last clip and this, okay? The
lawsuits have dropped. All right? So,
the Dynamic lawsuit and all that [__]
has come out, which means that
from Ethan's own side
in Ethan's legal filing, his lawyers
reference those takedowns. That's where
all those screenshots that I was showing
earlier came from. So,
any debate, any 1% doubt that you
possibly could have had about the
details of those DMCAs is gone.
It's gone because they're acknowledged
in Ethan's own legal filing. He has
acknowledged, "Yes, that Snark post is
actually correct.
Those are the clips we DMCA'd."
He's confirmed that.
Led me to the corn page, Christie,
because the Snark subreddit started
turning on you for associating with me.
Yada yada yada.
By the way, you You act like we're like
friendly or whatever. You spelt my name
wrong, you [__] [__] It's literally
in my [__] channel. My name is my
channel. It's extremely easy to spell it
right.
>> Now, I have had a parasocial love-hate
relationship with Nicholas Deorio for
quite some time.
>> think I've ever loved you. I respect him
as a content creator. I think he's
[__] fantastic. Thank you. uh What he
does, even if I don't agree with him.
However, as a person, I find him
insufferable, as he does with me. He
doesn't This is fair. This is a fair
argument. like me either. However, I
would say that there was a small amount
of morsel amount of mutual respect. I
stay in my corner, you stay in yours,
and we're good. However, when I found
out the update of Your corner is like
way off the side though. You're not
completely out of the way, you know?
>> the H3 Some would say it's like um, you
know, just like a little area off to the
side.
>> the H3 snark reddit, as well as the
lawsuits and legal documents and all of
that kind of stuff, Yeah, it was like I
explained out every time she has
parasocial love-hate relationship.
Obviously, that means one-sided
love-hate relationship. Then it goes,
"I've never loved you. I've never loved
you." Like a [__] [__] It's just
like so [__] stupid.
>> Nicholas DeOrio to let him know about
it. As you can see on the screen, this
is exactly what I said to Nick. Oh, she
leaked my DMs. I think I wrote back to
her knowing that she was going to leak
my DMs. That was the intention.
Um
Hey DeOrio, just leaving you a tip.
>> How do you Why do you keep Look at this.
Look at this. I actually need to [__]
point this out to you. How do you spell
my name wrong? It's
Look.
Hey DeOrio. Hey DeOrio. Hey DeOrio. How?
How? How do you click on someone's DMs
and spell their name wrong? How do you
do that?
How do you How do you [__] This is
insane.
Callis DeOrio. Now, I did this because
What did I say in this?
Cuz I stopped responding to her cuz I
realized that this wasn't like a
friendly conversation. This is content.
>> I responded However, as a person I find
him insufferable. Mutual respect. I stay
in my corner, you stay in yours, and
we're good. However, when I found out
the update of the H3 H3 snark reddit, as
well as the lawsuits and legal documents
and all of that kind of stuff, I reached
out to Nicholas DeOrio to let him know
about it. As you can see on the
Okay. Um
Let's see. It was, "Hi, just leaving you
a tip here. Ethan Klein has been abusing
the copyright system despite his history
of fighting for fair use." Well,
>> [laughter]
>> and now it seems like he's been
targeting things that were supposed to
be market replacements, but I I almost
think um So, no, it doesn't seem that
way actually, Nick. It doesn't seem that
way at all.
Um there's actually incontrovertible
proof, acknowledgement from Ethan's
lawyer that was not the case.
Actually, Nick.
I didn't even mention that on stream,
but it sounds like that's what they were
what he's mad about now is what he was
mad about then, right? But if he's
striking down posts
>> Yeah, what he's mad about now is what he
was mad about then. He's mad about
people criticizing him. That's why he
struck clips from non-member streams.
Uh they were simply there making fun of
him or criticizing him or people who
were on his stream, members of his crew
or his friends or whatever. That's why
he struck those.
From from non-member streams. It's cuz
yeah, cuz he is mad about the same. Very
true, Nick. Very true.
So they're here, watch this mirror, and
don't give Ethan the views. That's based
and best practices is what I said.
This is literally Do you know the
lawsuit stuff that happened recently?
This is back in This is in January. I
don't know how long these DM These DMs
might have even like crawled back into
um
December. But the rumor was he was
striking people who were doing market
replacement type content where it's like
intentionally pushing views away from
original content. So that was all that
I'd said was if that's the case, that's
probably like fine. No, he's not. I'd
say that would be fair also, but that's
not what he's doing. I have a question.
So what is
>> So So he reads out her saying that's not
the case. What's his response to that?
he's not. I'd say that would be fair
also, but that's not what he's doing. I
have a question. So what is Paige
Christie's current position on the
Denims, Frogan, and um
and Casey Thorne lawsuits? Are we going
to maintain this position? I'm just
curious. Cuz I feel like mine's fairly
consistent. Are we So he has he has no
response. He has no response. would
also. I'm just wondering.
Uh we're talking about clips that are 20
So he's he's read out
that's not what Ethan's doing. He's
actually striking non-members content.
So Nick's acknowledged that as a
possibility. Nick's response is not to
investigate. It's not to change his
take.
It's just to deflect and criticize
Paige.
That's not, you know, accidentally
missing something.
He knows what's there.
He's just trying to get away with it.
There is no way around this. And guys,
let's really
let's really seal the [__] deal here.
Let's really seal the [__] deal. For
anyone that's just like a total mong
either desperate to disagree
or
I don't even know, man. I truly don't
even know what type of [__] mong that
hangs around here doesn't get this yet.
But there are a few. There are a few who
still try to make excuses or act like it
wasn't totally intentional or whatever.
breaking Reddit post This one.
14th of August, guys. 14th of August.
>> Isn't that funny? We don't know for a
matter of fact that it was Mike. It's
just most likely Mike because of the I
don't I had to explain this last time.
People don't seem to understand it.
Twitch streamers have been DMCA-ing
streamable links in Reddit posts for
like a decade.
It was extremely common for them to be
striking clips. And no, it's not cool.
Uh we didn't think it was cool when Dark
Viper struck the clip of him uh getting
mad at Among Us.
>> [laughter]
>> When you're just doing 30-second clips,
40-second clips, and if that was what
Ethan was striking down, if they weren't
supposed to be market substitutes for
segments like don't give the stream the
view, watch it here. Yeah, I mean that's
kind of shitty. That's kind of cringey.
But none of these people operate in the
same
um
>> [clears throat]
>> None of these people operate in like the
same world, I guess. Badum Panada
striking a clip of a video that I own
most of the content of. So, you hear
that, right? So, he knows, but he still
gives a conditional.
He knows Ethan is
falsely DMCA-ing.
But he still gives a conditional and
then moves on to deflection because he
is deliberately trying to keep his
audience in the dark about the truth and
get away with it. It's a lie. He is
pretending to not know something when he
does know it.
It's a lie, clear as day.
That is lying. There's no way around it.
There is literally There is no argument
here.
So, any [__] idiot
who's still saying this stuff, please
come on stream. Please. I'm more than
happy to put you on the brink of tears
like I did to Beckett last night.
Speaking of which, let's take a look.
So, this is Beckett's attempt attempt
number two of this segment or attempt
number three maybe at this segment after
he [__] it up before. Let's have a
look. Let's play it first. Wait a
second.
Um
So,
right.
>> [snorts]
>> So,
first things first, right. Cool.
documents
Let's go.
We're going We're We're doing document
posting.
Oh, okay.
First off,
um
Right. So,
this appeared in the court documents.
This is what we're talking about. So,
there is a members-only thing.
Um
I'm being told it wasn't I mean wasn't
okay.
Let's just look at the court documents
for a second. So, what we're talking
about here, and this is my position on
this [__] by the way, okay? I'm not even
talking about Nick's position and why my
reaction to this is not outrage, abject
and horror
because as far as I was aware
there was DMCA takedown and stuff noted
in this court document towards the H3
[__] snark subreddit
forever.
Like, this doesn't shock me.
My position on all this is you shouldn't
be doing this
from the beginning.
Right?
So, these are like apparently the clips
that I took uh like being talked about
from like the mega heads.
Uh there's one thing that's like
>> to do. uh post contain uh containment a
complete version of TEA TEI's video H3
Podcast which was members-only content.
Everything else here, the argument I
believe and understand to be that Ethan
said was completely fair
to put up
and like people could react to.
Which is like I firstly I don't give a
[__] I don't give a [__] about this. I
don't care about members content. All of
this should be fair game in my view.
Wow, guys, Beckett doesn't care. Guys,
wow, isn't it miraculous how Beckett
doesn't care?
Once Once again, Beckett Actually
Actually, I think this is all bad, so I
just don't care.
It's [__] stuff put out on YouTube.
We all survive off fair use.
Uh this is just like basically
consistent stuff. I've said this
consistently. Like, I don't care whether
you upload somebody's full streams or
not. Um that's equally true for clips.
It shouldn't come down. But, that's like
the clips we're talking about, right?
Apparently. Guys, so much non-cha- or an
incredible incredible pedophilic swa-
>> Um let me just have a look at the dates
on these. Okay, so that's July 10th.
Beckett keeps it leisurely for sure.
>> May 3rd. So, that's May 3rd. Beckett
Type of guy who keeps it leisurely at
3:00 a.m.
100%.
first. So, this is before the lawsuit's
come out.
We'll have a look at his
uh response to some of this [__] Okay.
At Fox, had to sit and cry and get
scared for the night where they thought
the big mean Ethan Klein lawsuit was
going to be in the mail the next day. I
think that honestly, I think that
it should be make make [__] make
um vocal unhinged fans scared again.
Should be like the 2025 motto. Holy
[__] I I I'm the the verdict is out
>> No, I read the message you put in
a [__] server, [__]
Going off your timestamps here.
Going off that what you said, [__]
Okay. What?
This is on your You're you're
>> frivolous lawsuits to Redditors to
anonymous Redditors knowing full well
that they would be scared into
submission. You also posted about that
on your Instagram stories and
>> By the way, all right.
I think that's the basest part. Like
that's the best part of this is that
he's scared a bunch of Redditors into
[__] themselves and shutting an
entire subreddit down.
Absolutely. Go look up Go type in on H3
Snark and go read what they wrote about
Deorio and tell me how much I should
feel bad for them that these little
[__] rat [__] had to sit and cry and
get scared for the night where they
thought the big meanie Ethan Klein
lawsuit was going to be in the mail the
next day.
I think that honestly, I think that
it should be make make [__] make
um vocal unhinged fans scared again.
Should be like the 2025 motto. Holy
[__] I I I'm the the verdict is out on
whether I would defend these people uh
if Ethan went ahead and sued them, I
would need to see that on the actual
thing. But holy [__] dude, do I think
they deserve to shutter in fear for a
night? That'd be very funny.
>> knowing full well
Okay.
So,
I think this is a bit of an unhinged
comment,
but like
I get it to some extent. Um I have a
like a
a sick like thing of don't go off the
chatters. I think it's cringe when
anyone [__] does it. I don't think
anybody should give a [__] what like a
Reddit is thinking at all. Um
I don't think you should sue people over
Reddit comments. I think that's [__]
mental. I don't think you should defend
suing people over Reddit comments. Or
that they would be scared into
submission. You also posted about that
on your Instagram
What he is sharing is paywalled content.
The point that Ethan makes is that they
were posting stuff like, "Hey, don't
give this a click on Ethan's channel.
Here's a reupload." And those were the
things he had DMCA'd. That was That's
his argument. But again, I have not seen
this stuff. I don't know the nature of
the lawsuit. The clips aren't there. I
don't know how long they are. I can't
make any pro or against Ethan judgment
until I have more context. Defame you
and harass you? Can anonymous posters
Freedom of speech Dude, this is the best
part. The best part of being a free a
freedom of speech enthusiast is that I'm
not a freedom of speech absolutist.
Every freedom of speech absolutist gets
canceled because they start debating
[__] like child porn or something on
social He was messaging John 2025.
But was he told what was Okay.
So, he's told by Paige Christie in Jan
2025 that it's just clips, right? But
Ethan's argument, and indeed like what
Diorio is pointing to in the like
lawsuit, is this. Which from Diorio's
position is like this is fair to take
down.
He like keeps just focusing on the one
the one that you could argue is fair.
And he's acting like, "Oh, Diorio's just
referring to that."
He can't just There's five other false
DMCA's, bro. You can't just refer to one
and say that's all of them. What do you
mean, you [__] idiot? As until I see
the full lawsuit, what's in it,
I'm not making a full judgment. Now, I
assume from Diorio's position he'd
defend this, and he's leaving himself
open not to defend this.
One of these DMCA's is about
>> knows about those. Yes, that's how he's
lying, you [__] idiot. as well about
one position about this. And this is one
of the reasons that why I am getting
[__] annoyed. Um
Okay? I want to be like super clear of
why I'm not getting annoyed but I am
getting like frustrated. Cuz my position
and where I'm going to land on an
emotional level is I don't view these as
particularly [__] different. Uh
listen to how many [__] excuses he
tries to throw out here. Actually, this
is all the same This is all the same.
So, why you You know, why why go after
Nick for some not sleeping for some of
it when it's all about It's like
literally everything he can try try and
do.
Becket sounds so fearful uh tearful
tearful.
Yeah. This is what he means by he
doesn't want to get involved cuz he
clearly He says he doesn't care. He says
he doesn't want to get involved. No, you
don't want to get involved cuz you do
care.
Cuz you care about your position here.
It's obviously true to anyone watching.
I'm say I'm sick of this [__] I'm legit
sick of this [__] This why Halberd has
annoyed me here. Not only because she
was totally [__] wrong and said that
I hadn't played the clip I had played,
but also because
uh there are retards on the internet.
Uh and because these people are like
totally [__] and can't read social
situations or don't understand the
dynamics in conversations,
um
they just endlessly run defense for
people who are obviously being
dishonest.
And we're done with that. We are We're
just totally done with that.
It's totally insufferable.
Uh it happens a bunch in this
conversation with Beckett.
And legit, if you if you watch this and
you can't see what's going on in
Beckett's head,
I worry for you. Especially if you
assume the conversation I remembered
this after Insight as an example here.
But you remember that Leo convoy
conversation I had with Beckett like a
month or two ago where this guy's like,
"I just don't want to use the word
abuse. I just don't want to use the word
abuse." when it's the most like absurd
situation you've ever heard of of some
fat old man who claims to be
you know, a a Christian you know, good
Samaritan type moving in abused like
late teenagers like you know,
19-year-olds into into his place or
across the country and then either
You know what I mean? It's like
and you say it you say it that sounds
really abusive Becca. That sounds like
abuse. I don't want to use that word. I
don't want to use that word.
It's the same thing happens here.
And yeah, retards will just allow that
[__] to fly.
They just allow it to fly.
They they think um
You know, it is genuinely I believe it's
like an autism thing. It's like you have
to take people at face value. It's like
you take everyone at face value. No,
don't take people at face value. Think
why are they saying that?
There's usually a reason why they're
acting weird about something.
Thank you for the membership federal
rate. Thank you.
Okay. So, like that's where I'm coming
from with my general take on this. I
just want to be hyper clicks. I feel
like now I have to be.
I think all the [__] takedowns and
the lawsuits are bad for the ecosystem.
I'm critical of I know I just told you
hell then. I'm saying about [__]
generating. I literally it's like the
whole of Beckett's chat was like getting
like legitimately confused.
It's like it's like baffling. Everyone
who has defended them.
That is my consistent position.
It has been on all this stuff. I tweet
this out immediately when the lawsuits
dropped in [__] June.
The day of the diaper is here. Diaper
sweepers have zero absorption. Thank you
for the $4.99. Thank you.
comedian. Have you noticed this?
Everyone who calls himself a free speech
absolutist has some weird CP
conversation on social media and then
everyone stops calling them. They just
stop going on shows. That That's the
only way that you could be a free speech
absolutist if you have a really bad take
on like child porn or something.
Um
>> [laughter]
>> No, realistically, my principal says
that like I might not agree with this
lawsuit. My principal doesn't say I have
to defend people who are completely
[__] slandering me. It just means I'd
abstain from the conversation if I don't
support it. That's where I would stand
on it. Yeah, I don't know. I I think
these people deserve to sweat. My My
just my opinion.
Literally posted
Again, that's his position. I disagree
with it. I think you defend people even
if you disagree with them, even you
[__] hate them because it's a wider
thing within the ecosystem.
Like
if somebody struck Jeremy,
I would defend Jeremy. When the KP stuff
happened, I said do not strike KP. I am
fully within my bounds to like go and
strike KP's archival channel. I'm not
doing it, regardless of how I feel about
it. I've encouraged people not to flag
down. Those are my positions. I Again,
disagree with Nick. I think this is like
>> [snorts]
>> I I disagree with this position.
But
again, I That's his position. It's
publicly stated.
He's literally telling you he's dodging
the story. He sent the evidence for the
stuff and he
and he wouldn't support and he's
avoiding the evidence while saying
that's what he'd do.
He was waiting for the lawsuits to come
out. This is like me. This is before the
lawsuits are there. And Ethan's saying
what he's striking is this.
Like
Like okay, unless I'm missing a clip
somewhere of Ethan saying yes, I took
down the clips.
Dude.
I understand why a YouTube creator would
mind this. It could open the floodgates.
Yes. Just my consistent position.
Well, yeah, that's what people people
are asking you about your position on
DMCA's back at. That is what you're
being asked right now, actually, isn't
it?
Not?
Not at all? Oh, it's I'll be like, "Oh,
yeah, that's pretty bad. I don't really
agree with that." And then I'll cover
whatever else is on the topic or the
docket that day. You're not entitled to
my support. Okay, hold on. Let me say
>> People deserve to sweat. My My just my
opinion.
Literally posted fake a doctor post.
>> I'll be like, "Oh, yeah, that's pretty
bad."
>> understand why he kept repeating what
his stance was. Um
So, basically, I accused Beckett of this
in DMs, so I'll say it again publicly.
What Beckett likes to do is this is a
tactic. It is a tactic and it is a
dishonest tactic. It's whenever he's
getting pressed for a specific stance,
he will retreat to a general stance
trying to avoid saying something that
might cause him problems.
So, he will he will endlessly endlessly
endlessly hammer,
"I don't agree with DMCA's. I don't
agree with DMCA's."
So, that his audience feel like he's
taking a stance on it, or so that, you
know, I feel like he's taking a stance
on it. But then when you actually press
him for what you're asking about, he
will cut it That's where he keeps going
back to. That's where he keeps going
back to.
I don't really agree with that. And then
I'll cover whatever else is on the topic
or the docket that day. You're not
entitled to my support.
Posted it on our subreddit saying I was
banning people who were wishing a happy
Ramadan.
Wait, hold on.
Isn't he just saying he doesn't give a
[__] about the H3 Snark people, then?
He's like, he may disagree and not
support it, but he's not going to launch
like a defense
>> It's It's just so obvious what's
happening here. He is motivated to find
a way to thread the needle.
It's just so I I don't, truly.
I said to him in chat, like, "Do you
really think this is going to Do you
really think this works? Do you really
think this works?" It's just so apparent
how desperate he is to thread the
needle.
Blows my mind, really.
It gets bad, guys. It gets really bad.
>> I disagree with.
Right.
Queen man.
Yo. Okay, Beckett. What what are you not
getting here?
There are There are strikes, DMCA
strikes, and then there are lawsuits.
Hassan says "suing Redditors". He means
strikes. He's talking about the strikes.
He said "you filed frivolous lawsuits".
He means false DMCA strikes.
Ethan knows what's what he means. He
engages on that that basis. That's what
they end up talking about. Nick knows
that's what's being said. He engages
with that and says that it's about
members only content being struck.
Nick says "as far as the lawsuits, I'd
have to see what comes in there".
So, disregard the lawsuits. I don't know
why you're saying he has to wait for
lawsuits to be stake. No, he doesn't.
That's separate to the DMCA strikes.
So, why do you keep saying that?
>> Because that's not how it sounds to me.
What it sounds like to me
>> How is that not the case, Beckett? Well,
okay. That's fine. That's fine. That's
fine. What it sounds like to me is Nick
saying "okay, well, if he's going after
them for like the members only content",
which is Ethan's argument. They're
talking about the lawsuit. I I agree
with you. Hassan means the strikes.
>> No. No. No. You're rambling. Explain how
that's not the case, Beckett. Explain
how the lawsuit and the DMCAs are not
the same.
>> my mind debate. But aren't the DMCAs the
things you just sent me listed in the
lawsuit?
Yes, they are referenced in the lawsuit.
Okay.
But Okay.
But the DMCAs happened
far before the lawsuit, and all the
information about the public the DMCAs
was public far before the lawsuit. What
do you mean by public? It's like
It was public. It was all public. The
legal letters were all public. They'd
been posted everywhere.
Can you send me a copy?
I don't know the story, so please send
me the copy, okay? I'm
>> I've I've keep playing this out to you,
Becca. This is why I'm getting
frustrated.
>> So, we we go and look for basically the
snow credit post. With that the show as
taken down.
Yeah, I don't have an original copy.
You don't You don't have the original
one, okay.
I come 25.
Okay.
So, we're totally clear. Um Yeah, that's
fine. That's fine.
Where is this dick has pulled this up
yesterday? Today I should find it.
This day one.
Pop in this thing. Pop right strike
there. And this is sent to Nick. January
2025 or December 2024, maybe.
Okay, give me a second.
Yeah.
Yeah, I I mean, again,
they should have been covered. I mean,
I'll watch the like other streams you
said. Okay, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, hold on,
hold on, hold on, hold on.
Not Not just a shoe and covered.
And I I want you to answer this
question, Becca.
>> Sure.
Is it a lie for Nick, having been
presented the evidence,
to say, as a conditional, "Oh, well, if
he wasn't striking members-only content,
I wouldn't support that, but I also just
wouldn't cover it." Is it a lie to his
audience to imply that he does not have
that information, that he cannot make
that verdict yet?
Okay, I want to be really
I want to re-listen to this.
I want to be really clear
>> Just Just answer the question by the end
of the segment. Watch both the videos,
okay? Sure. Sure. I'll I'll I'll I'll
let you go back to it. That's fine.
Okay, sure. That's fine.
So, I do call back in, guys. I do call
back.
>> Okay, cuz I want to be really clear. If
Di Oreo
is misleading the audience on this,
and that deserves to be like noted and
called out. That's fine.
That's fine. Fine, I guess. Fine. Okay.
See, it's like [__] pulling teeth
with these people, man. It is like
actually like [__] pulling teeth.
It's so crazy.
But, fine. I guess I guess if
Well, my friends, is Daily Pretty lying
to his audience in order to cover up the
copyright abuse that infringed on the
free speech of anonymous users the way
we usually protect under any other
situation we would usually kick up a
huge fuss over. But, I I guess that's
bad. Fine. Fine.
Becket,
you're a commentator, Becket.
Give your [__] opinion. Stand on
something. Have a spine.
Okay. Sure.
I'm going to re-listen to just a bit of
this with this Hasan stuff. Let's go
back.
I don't even understand what's
happening. So, I think the basic
argument here is cuz when I listen to
this, I hear them talking about the
lawsuits. I hear Di Oreo talking about
the lawsuits. And the argument from
Queen and side is that actually they're
not engaging about the lawsuits.
They're engaging about the DMCA strikes
that occurred on Reddit.
And that was like the shuddering effect
or like the chilling effect that Di Oreo
is referencing, right? And then Di Oreo
brings it back to the lawsuits.
You wanted to Whoa, whoa, whoa. You
wanted to dox them
>> I to their families. How did I What?
This is on your your your frivolous
lawsuits to Redditors, to anonymous
Redditors, knowing full well that they
would be scared into submission. You
also posted about that on your Instagram
stories, by
>> By
All right.
Sent anonymous lawsuits to the Redditors
to to scare them into submission.
Just to be clear, Hassan calls them
lawsuits because Ethan's lawyer was the
one filing the claims and sending DNC
letters. It's just shorthand.
But we
like, okay.
Okay.
I think that's the bestest part. Like
that's the best part of this is that he
scared a bunch of Redditors into just
[__] themselves and shutting an
entire subreddit down.
Absolutely. Go look up Go type in on H3
Snark and go read what they wrote about
Diorio and tell me how much I should
feel bad for them that these little
[__] rat [__] had to sit and cry and
get scared for the night where they
thought the big mean Ethan Klein lawsuit
was going to be in the mail the next
day. I think that honestly I think that
it should be make make [__]
The good timeline if Orgy Arcee decides
to react to the Keemstar Tonic's video
this weekend. Nick Mosco, Orgy leaves
Diorio's foundation on Raw Live.
Awesome. Awesome. Make
um vocal unhinged fans scared again.
Should be like the 2025 model. Yo, look.
Can you do me a favor? If you have the
letter, if you just put a video
together, can you just DM me the [__]
letter?
Is that cool? Can you do that?
Dude.
Good evening, Bug Squad. How you doing,
buddy? Oh, holy [__] I I'm
I'm not sure whether he's out or whether
I would defend these people.
>> think I think he said
Do you need a women's shelter or
something like that? I think he said you
need a women's shelter You he's going to
call a women's shelter for you, Becca,
or some [__] like that. Well, uh if
Ethan went ahead and sued them, I would
need to see that on the actual face.
>> Thank you for the membership. Thank you.
Okay. To me, that is very specifically
Nick talking about lawsuits towards
>> what did he say? Holy [__] I I'm the
the verdict is out on whether I would
defend these people. If Ethan went ahead
and sued them, I would need to see that
on the actual thing.
>> Okay, to me So yeah, that one comment he
is saying, "I don't know if I would
support if Ethan fully sued them." Okay,
yes, that's a comment on lawsuits. That
one comment is a comment on lawsuits.
>> is very specifically Nick talking about
lawsuits towards the Redditors.
Right?
He's not engaging.
Sure, he's not engaging
with the conversation about the DMCAs.
If that's what this conversation between
Hasan and Ethan is, I'm dying to take
that as the shorthand of the way Hasan
is talking about it.
But holy [__] dude, do I think they
deserve to shutter in fear for a night?
That'd be very funny.
>> Think FloWrestling would be scared into
submission. You also posted about that
on your Instagram stories as well.
>> Can anonymous Redditor what they're
sharing is paywalled content. The The
point that Ethan makes is that they were
posting stuff like, "Hey, don't give
this a click on Ethan's channel. Here's
a reupload." And those were the things
he had DMCA'd.
That was That's his argument. But again,
I have not seen this stuff. I don't know
the nature of the lawsuit. The clips
aren't there. I don't know how long they
are. I can't make any pro or against
Ethan. I don't think the DMCA was even
registered in Nick's head. I mean,
there's a bit of mind reading here. Um
okay, sure. At the very least at the
very least, he should have should have
been [__] aware of that because this
is content he is covering and has
covered in detail. I I I've done this
with other people as well. I think lying
is a really high bar.
That is about the DMCA. Wind that back.
Yeah, hold on.
into submission. You
to shutter in fear for a night. That'd
be very funny. Think FloWrestling they
would be scared into submission. You
also posted about that on your Instagram
stories as well.
Weren't they sharing his paywalled
content? The The point that Ethan makes
is that they were But the anonymous
Okay, but if it's about the anonymous
paywalled content that was struck off
Reddit, which had been a conversation
and appears in the lawsuit, if that's
the thing Nick is focusing on, Nick
would be fine with that because Nick's
position position is you can strike
>> If that's the thing Nick's focusing on,
what do you mean? That's the lie. The
fact he knows there's other stuff.
He's focusing on one example as the only
example
and then dismissing it. That's the lie,
Beckett. He knows that's not the only
thing, but he's pretending it is.
So that when you when you know something
to be true
and you pretend you don't
you're lying.
Hopefully that's clear. Hope we're we're
all on the same Anyone disagree with
that definition of lying or that example
of a lie? Anyone disagree that's
something other than a lie? Wait, you
know something to be true.
You pretend you don't.
And then you focus on an opposite
example
and act like that's the only example.
That's a lie. I hope we're all we're all
in agreement there. That is conscious,
willing dishonesty.
Saying something that is untrue.
You are delivering a a false impression.
market replacements, which is what Ethan
is pushing for through this entire like
thing of like Well, they I don't know
about watch Beckett. Does he usually
refuse to engage in obvious inference?
Uh when it's about his friends, yes.
Yes, in my experience. Now, Beckett
claims Actually, yes. He always refuses
to engage in inference like some sort of
[__] That's what Beckett actually
claims to me.
Uh I haven't watched enough of his
content now to be 100% true.
I doubt it, personally. I really doubt
it.
They're doing a market replacement. So
there's like that content should come
down. That's his whole argument in the
[__] lawsuits.
>> They call him Becca the great friend.
They call him Becca Becca the great
friend.
>> [__] clips. Like and sure, if you
want to say, "Well, that's Nick just
honestly pivoting or something." I can
see how you'd see that.
But he knows that's not the only thing,
[__] Yeah, but wouldn't that be the
main thing?
Dude.
And wouldn't that be like the overriding
thing with this conversation? It's like,
well, is there legitimate stuff there?
And if unless Nick has a
No.
Doing one false DMCA, sorry, doing one
act
um legitimate DMCA does not mean your
false DMCAs are also legitimate. What a
stupid [__] argument Becca is making.
Seriously. How does anyone I don't I
truly I love Becca. I love I do love
Becca. I do love Becca, okay?
How does anyone watch someone who makes
arguments this [__] stupid, truly?
When it's this [__] bad, how do you
How do you do it? I don't understand. I
legit do not understand.
The only thing that makes sense is his
audience is disabled. Only thing that
makes sense. It's the only thing that
makes sense. I do not understand how you
listen to someone talk like this about
their opinions on drama.
Where they Where they are they are
legitimately in the moment, their
response to this is to say,
"Well, isn't the overriding thing
whether one of them is legitimate?" No,
it's not, you [__] [__] Obviously.
If I have, you know, again, I bring up a
rape analogy later in this, but if you
have consensual sex someone time, does
it make the five rapes not count? No,
obviously not, you [__] [__] You
can put it on to any any wrongdoing any
wrongdoing. You can apply this to. It
never never makes it okay. Literally,
there's a no situation ever has ever
been a good argument, period. So, the
idea that it's even on the tip of your
tongue to say you should be [__]
ashamed. I love Beckett, but you should
be [__] ashamed, truly. The fact you
go out and say this [__] that should
bother you. You should think about that
at night. I'm serious. I'm so [__]
serious.
a list
Okay, let me see this letter from
Keemstar.
Um Right, let me see.
Okay, this is April.
So, Ethan Klein isn't just going after
public figures criticizing, he's also
threatening litigation against random
people. So, so this is April. This is
one of the the victims of a false NCA
strike who has been threatened.
Uh this person April 11th. You see that?
You see that? So, do we remember the
timeline here, guys? Let's refresh
ourselves.
So, January
Nick is informed that they're false.
Um
May
Nick reacts to the H3 Ethan
H3 sign debate
and pretends he doesn't know that some
of them are false.
So, already in April, so this is before
the lawsuits are out which confirm it
from Ethan's side, there is additional
evidence. This person posts very
publicly, and this is widely circulated
and never denied by Ethan in any way. I
think even tacitly confirmed by Ethan on
his Instagram stories, I believe. I'm
pretty sure tacitly confirmed by Ethan
on his Instagram stories.
In April of 2025, this is public.
So, that's another thing that Nick
already knows when he goes to the
debate, when he goes to review the
Paytch Cristy video, there is no excuse.
There's no excuse, period. Nothing.
There's nothing you can draw on here to
try and exonerate Nick.
There is literally nothing. He knew
just cleanly. He [__] swept. It's
just clear as [__] day.
People like me allegedly posted a minute
and a half long clip on reddit.com.
reddit.com. Lamarr, you have to be
kidding me.
Okay.
I remember I remember bits about this
conversation
and people being like, "Oh, well, you
know, the H3 snarkers are getting what
they get because he's going off on
Didn't people like
call this out as well?
I feel like some of this just isn't new
and isn't
>> This is literally This is a DG J line.
This is a
DG line.
This isn't even new. This isn't even
new.
Dude, he
He threatened to release revenge porn on
Anna if she did
If she leaked sexual details about him
years ago. That isn't even new. That
isn't even new.
Shut the [__] up. What do you mean it
isn't even new? Where's your [__]
segment on it then, [__] if it
isn't new?
nation. Anyway. Anyway. Okay.
Sure.
Okay.
Also, hold on.
Cuz Ni- Cuz like
Ethan was talking publicly about going
after the H3 people in any way H3 snark
people in any way he could, right? And
Nick brings this up and is like, "I
don't know if I'd defend these people if
they actually got sued or not. I might
just be silent on it."
Like, "Hey, don't give this a click on
Ethan's channel."
by the way, I disagree with. I think you
should defend those people even if
they're [__] snarkers. But anyway.
Well, here's a re-upload. And those were
the things he had DMCA'd.
That was That's his argument. But again,
I have not seen this stuff. I don't know
the nature of the lawsuit. The clips
aren't there. I don't know how long they
are. I can't make any pro or against
Ethan judgment until I have more
context. defend you and harass you? Can
anonymous posters Freedom of speech
Dude, this is the best part. The best
part of being a free freedom of speech
enthusiast is that I'm not a freedom of
speech absolutist. Every freedom of
speech absolutist gets canceled because
they start debating [__] like child
porn or something on social media. Have
you noticed this? Everyone who calls
himself a free speech absolutist has
some weird CP conversation on social
media and then everyone stops calling
them. They just stop going on shows.
That That's the only way that you can be
a free speech absolutist is if you have
a really bad take on like child porn or
something.
Um
>> [laughter]
>> No, really. It's Okay, we're going to
actually watch a little bit more cuz I
watched it all.
>> that like I might not agree with this
lawsuit. My principle doesn't say I have
to defend people who are completely
[__] slandering me. It just means I'd
abstain from the conversation if I don't
support it. That's where I would stand
on it.
Yeah, I don't know. I I think these
people deserve to sweat. My My just my
opinion.
Literally posted fake a doctored post.
>> I'd be like, oh yeah, that's pretty bad.
I don't really agree with that. And then
I'd cover whatever else is on the topic
or the docket that day. You're not
entitled to my support.
posted it on our subreddit saying I was
banning people who were wishing a happy
Ramadan. Okay.
Okay, we're going to move on to Nick's
coverage in the Adam McIntyre stuff.
Let's do this one.
show that we never actually got around
to watch.
Paige Christie. Yeah, those unemployed
snark people are the worst.
Did you ever make a video?
This one.
>> It's in decline.
>> I got 2 seconds You can tell I got two
seconds into it. Uh let's see. What are
we seeing here?
Let me see.
Let's take a look.
Nicholas
Let me see. Actually, let's just go to
Snark.
Oh, 50 mentions.
Interesting. Friendly fire, Nicholas De
Oreo. What was his segment about?
>> friendly-ish way, I guess. Nicholas De
Oreo. Now, whilst in a live stream,
Nicholas De Oreo, as he should have done
>> just thinking like legit
that that you know, my annoyance with
people not calling out um
you know, like Beckett's tactics and
[__] like this.
It just made It does make me miss Mr.
Girl, man. It makes me miss Mr. Girl
content so much. He's the one guy that
would actually just hold up a
conversation. Just stop be like, wait.
You're being dishonest with me in this
really subtle way. Or you need to argue
about this for the next half an hour.
You need to admit that you're being
dishonest with me in this really subtle
way, otherwise we can't continue with
this conversation.
That was just so That [__] was just so
real.
Yeah, Beckett hates Mr. Girl because he
did that to Stardust.
Because Stardust, dude, go watch the
Stardust and Mr. Girl stuff.
He read her so obviously. It's so funny
how [__] crazy she gets over it, man.
It's so [__] funny. Because he
describes um
Basically, Stardust the Stardust lady
basically says, because of her sexual
trauma, she doesn't have sex with guys
until like the the fifth date or some
stupid [__] like that. I can't remember.
And Mr. Girl is like uh that's a power
play. That's a power play. You're doing
that because you feel like you need
power in that situation. Obviously true.
And if you evaluate that as a
dispassionate neutral statement and not
as an insult
you can see that's obviously true. That
doesn't make it like this horrible
[__] thing or starts a horrible
[__] fuss. He's just saying obviously
you feel worried that you're going to
lose
uh
power. You're you're going to feel
powerless. So, you need to maintain
power in that relationship.
And she freaks the [__] out over it. She
literally freaks the [__] out over it,
basically accuses him of sexual
harassment, all this [__] Has to hash
it out with Chad. Like dude, it's so
it's just so funny.
frequently. I ended up sh-
>> [laughter]
>> Wait, she's right. I did. I actually
did. No. No, I leaked all my DMs, bro.
You can see my messages with Mauler.
showing his inbox on Twitter. To which
people had noticed that AB, one of the
members of the H3H3 podcast, was in
Nicholas Deorio's DMs. What was my DM?
Wait, hold on. What was it? What did I
say to AB? I can tell you what it is.
No problem. Let me say What was no
problem? I actually wonder what the
context of this DM was cuz I only have
like a few DMs with AB. So, it'll take
like 2 seconds to find. Was this when I
warned him about I I This might be when
I warned him about Bad Empanada
um before all the drama started.
Cuz uh
no prob- uh um oh.
It was to send a I sent along the
Rosanna AB thumbnail thing. That's what
that was.
That was on January 6th.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude, the most iconic January 6th
reveal. his inbox on Twitter.
>> Who is in here? Wait, do Oh my god.
Dude, this is [__]
Wait. Dude, these DMs are ridiculous.
Look at all the names, bro. This is like
actually [__] insane. Dude, so
there's just one guy There's a fake
Augie, Mr. Beast, Lieutenant Cobra,
Alex Yekmo, Colossal is crazy, Paige
Christie, Mauler, the Boston Tea Party
group chat from the iconic leaks, and
then the house group chat which was the
Boston Tea Party without Keemstar for
Bowblax that we kicked Bowblax from.
This is like a This is a ridicu- Dude,
Tipster. Dude, it's Tipster, fake Augie,
Mr. Beast's lieutenant Cobra.
>> Yo,
the nails for the 100 season K. Thank
you. You do appreciate it with the Shiba
Inu with two little fans waving around.
Thank you. You do appreciate it. And
Colossal is crazy.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude, I'm actually like actually right.
I am a complete [__] idiot for this.
Holy [__] dude. And And was there Muta
har in there, too? Do you see Muta? I
don't see Muta. Stop. To which people
had noticed that AB, one of the members
of the H3H3 pod- It's not really fair to
critique this in current day. Now, this
was made a long time ago.
>> was in Nicholas DeOrio's DMs. Other
members of the H3 Snark Reddit had also
noticed that my name So, I'm just
letting this play. I don't really like
even mind for the segment that Nick was
aware of the Paige Christie video and
was sent the list [music] of struck
material in January.
Okay.
Who is that, too?
>> [music]
>> Thank you for the five gifted
Cloverbell. I huge appreciate it. Thank
you, Cloverbell. Thank you. Oh, and that
started the whole we don't like Paige.
She supports
Wait, so is that why you sent me to the
corn, Paige Christie? Because the snark
subreddit started turning on you for
associating with me? Yada yada yada.
By the way, you you act like we're like
friendlier or whatever. You spelt my
name wrong, you [__] [__] It's
literally in my [__] channel. My name
is my channel. It's extremely easy to
spell it right.
>> Now, I have had a parasocial love-hate
relationship with Nicholas DeOrio for
quite some time.
>> think I've ever loved you. I respect him
as a content
>> trauma is never going to end, is it?
It No.
Eventually, somebody will die. It's I
think he's [__] fantastic. Thank you.
what he does, even if I don't agree with
him. However, as a person I find him
insufferable as he does with me. He
doesn't This is fair. This is a fair
argument.
>> like me either. However, I would say
that there was a small amount of morsel
amount of mutual respect. I stay in my
corner, you stay in yours, and we're
good. However, when I found out the
update of Your corner is like way off to
the side though, you know, completely
out of the way, you know, it's like a
little area off to the side. It's like
you know, it's just like a little area
off to the
>> PHD Snark Reddit as well as the lawsuits
and legal documents and all of that kind
of stuff. I reached out to Nicholas
DeOrio to let him know about it. As you
can see on the screen, this is exactly
what I said to Nick Oh, she leaked my
DMs. I think I wrote back to her knowing
that she was going to leak my DMs. That
was the intention.
Um
hey DeOrio, just leaked linktree
Quayman Clips. I'm going to link it in
the chat. This will take you to
Instagram, Tik Tok, YouTube, and Twitter
pages
that you should follow right now. If you
use any of those platforms, you should
go there and follow those platforms
right now
where there are clips posted. There are
edited clips posted.
And just remember to say, you know,
give those a like if you see them. Give
those a like. Give those a share.
Um maybe you'll feel inspired to post on
those platforms yourself. leaving you a
text. How do you Why do you keep Look at
this. Look at this. I actually need to
[__] point this out to you. How do
you spell my name wrong? It's
Look.
Hey DeOrio. Hey DeOrio. 44 with two.
I'll care about Kayman when he makes his
own stuff. Queen makes his own stuff. He
does make videos very occasionally.
Brio. Hey DeOrio. How?
How? How do you click on someone's DMs
and spell their name wrong? Dude, can
you believe some people haven't seen my
Briana Wu video and debate? Can you
believe that guys? Norse hasn't seen it.
Norse hasn't seen my Briana Wu video and
debate.
Can you believe that guys?
do that.
How do you How do you [__] This is
insane.
Clis DeOrio. Now, I did this because
what What did I say in this?
Cuz I stopped responding to her cuz I
realized that this wasn't like a
friendly conversation. This is content.
>> I respond However, as a person I find
him insufferable. mutual respect. I say
in my corner, you stay in yours and
we're good. However, when I found out
the update of the H3H3 snark Reddit, as
well as the lawsuits and legal documents
and all of that kind of stuff, I reached
out to Nicholas DeOrio to let him know
about it. As you can see on the
Okay.
Um
let's see. It was, "Hi, just leaving you
a tip here. Ethan Klein has been abusing
the copyright system despite his history
of fighting for fair use." Well,
>> [laughter]
>> now it seems like he's been targeting
things that were supposed to be market
replacements, but I I almost think um
I didn't even mention that on stream,
but it sounds like that's what they were
that like what he's mad about now is
what he was mad about then, right? But I
If he's striking down posts that are
here, watch this mirror and don't give
Ethan the views, that's based and best
practices is what I said.
This is literally Do you know the
lawsuit stuff that happened
>> So, this is like the early conversation
that was happening. At this point in
July, DeOrio should know that there was
other stuff that was going on
with the DMCA's on Reddit, which was for
clips.
You think like again, like he'd been
covering a load of this stuff.
So, it is a bit of a diversion
at the very least.
It's a diversion, guys.
>> Does not Yeah, no, okay, sure. Is that
calling again?
>> covering this. That's his main content,
sure. Jesus. And recently, this is back
in This is in January. I don't know how
long these DM These DMs might have even
like crawled back into um
December. But the rumor was he was
striking people who were doing market
replacement type content where it's But
also, hold on. Is the chat message
highlighting [__] kind of sucks, let's
be real.
It's real It looks tacky, man. It just
looks tacky. I hate You know, I hate
stream stuff. I hate stream stuff.
Christie. Somebody he doesn't get on
>> If I could literally If I could just red
bar it, you know, if I could just red
bar it like I'm just sitting there with
tea. I would. I would. Has barely any
[__] conversations with and just gets
randomly reached out to and then pivot
like and immediately he's dealing with
other content. I don't think he even did
much like [__] Ethan stuff during
this time in January. It was all Bowflex
and [__] Destiny, wasn't it?
And by the time we come to this, it's
like what? 6 months later?
Like intentionally pushing views away
from original content. So that was all
that I had said was if that's the case,
that's probably like fine. No, he's not.
I'd say that would be fair also, but
that's not what he's doing. I have a
question. So what is Paige Christie's
current position on the Denims, Frogan
He's just such a rat.
>> and Casey Tron board. He's just so
disgusting. Are we going to maintain
this position? I'm just curious. Cuz I
feel like mine's fairly consistent. Are
we going to maintain this position that
that would be fair also? I'm just
wondering. Uh we're talking Okay. At
this point it's clear that Paige is also
talking about these other [__]
um DMCA takedowns. Nick is ignoring that
fact. talking about clips that are 20
seconds to 1 minute.
Not exactly intending to rip off a third
party
>> there. We're getting there. for a formal
video to break this down.
Or I was waiting for Ethan to announce a
lawsuit. We mentioned this like [__]
multiple times.
I was waiting to see what would actually
get taken down cuz I don't necessarily
take whatever some person writes as a
snark subreddit as fact. I've seen what
they write about me. I don't necessarily
believe everything that I read on a
snark subreddit. You have to take stuff
like that with a grain of salt. It never
really happened. Uh and then the the
lawsuits that actually came out came
out. So that was kind of that. screen
This is a
Okay.
And the focus here is the lawsuits and
it would have been a in July.
Not bringing up the DMCAs is like
I say it's dishonest. It's not the full
picture. It's certainly like refocused
like onto where Nick is like
>> [snorts]
>> What is he in this content where he
wants to place it. Seriously, try and
explain his point to me here.
Seriously, so I'm begging. I'm begging
someone to explain what the [__] he's
even trying to say here.
Seriously.
What is he trying to say here?
I don't I legit don't understand. I was
like watching this last night. So much
of it I'm just like, Beckett, you're
just in got you're just saying things.
You were just saying things. None of it
actually maps onto any real
distinctions. You're not actually
identifying anything that's happening.
You're just saying [__]
You say, "Oh, Nick's not talking about
the DMCAs."
No, he he is. He's just not talking
about the ones that he would disagree
with. Again.
Even though it's right there.
What is that, Beckett?
What is that?
I just I Okay, sure. Exactly what I said
to Nicholas DeOrio. Now, I did this
because whilst Nicholas DeOrio will suck
the literal skin off Ethan Klein's This
is in January, by the way. I think I How
many videos had I made about Ethan Klein
by January? Was it like dude, holy [__]
She probably has such a horrible [__]
idea of me now. She probably [__]
hates me now. Holy [__] dude. This is
You got to understand this is
pre-content nuke, too. This is January.
That's crazy.
>> phallic object. I do believe that Nick
Okay, another thing, Paige Christie has
this like weird habit of making
everything about like sucking [__] and
and [__] I think she was fighting
with Augie. It was like, "I'm going to
go [__] something my whatever." Like
I
A lot of weird sexual energy coming off
of her. skin off Ethan Klein's phallic
object. That's gross. I do believe that
Nicholas DeOrio is a man Now, why can
you say this? Why can you say that I
suck the Ethan's phallic [__] or
something, but God forbid we make a joke
about like iDubbz Well, pay Well, Nick,
it's because when Paige Christie talks
about you sucking Ethan Klein's dick,
she doesn't sound like, nor does anyone
believe, that she's into it while saying
it. When you talk about Anisa Joma,
it comes off a little bit different
then. That's why. and his wife and we're
misogynistic pieces of [__] incel
[__] What is this like crazy double
standard where like if it's two guys,
you can talk about them literally
sucking [__] and it's totally above
board.
>> word. And he understands that fair is
fair. And he is more than willing to
call out friends, which I've seen
numerous times on his career.
>> Dan Saw Men, looking at you.
>> I don't know. I'm actually friends is a
little bit of a stretch. for the good
>> John Swan! of what is right. I literally
saw this boy disown his very good
friend, John Swan, I thought you were
going to say Bob Lax. over lies is that
he told that reflected bad on the
commentary community. Nicholas Deorio
went Dude, she cared so much about this
that she went DM me, immediately clipped
them, set them up for the video, and
dropped them in here instead of actually
expressing that.
>> out of his way to make a stance and say,
"This is [__] up and I don't stand by
it."
>> I'm just like what comment what uh order
of DMs would I have had to send to her
for her not to use this as content? No,
I did what I wanted to do in my way.
>> I've done plenty of these plenty of
times, but like I know when somebody's
doing it to me, so I I know when to stop
responding to somebody.
>> to myself that maybe
>> to even what he says there.
He's saying He's trying to give himself
as much plausible deniability in those
DMs as possible. He's trying not to get
caught saying anything.
It's clear as day. There's no way around
this, man.
Your Any Deorio defender is raped. You
cannot defend this. It's done. It's
done.
Nicholas Deorio just simply doesn't care
about copyright law and copyright
infringements and false copyright
claims. But no, Nicholas Deorio also has
a patented history of speaking about
copyright infringements within his
>> I would be so [__] Yeah.
Yeah, Nick should have talked about the
DMCA's on Reddit.
He should have talked Yeah, he should
have talked about it.
>> [laughter]
>> I don't know what else I'm meant to say.
Like, yes, he should have talked about
this stuff. He should have
uh spent more time, I don't know,
essentially addressing the DMs.
He moves on very quickly from it.
And then it becomes into this wider
thing about Nick's behavior.
Not should have talked about it, he just
did, he lied.
I don't know.
I don't know, ignoring it. Like, I keep
going back to the earlier statement of
like, do I need to like offer my support
when he's like, I might not even talk
like talk about it with people I don't
give a [__] about. He's not condoning
the DMCA strikes on to on the Redditors.
He's just like, not saying He literally
did, by the way. He literally did.
He literally did. He literally said,
"Yeah, I mean, if that happens to
Redditors, I don't give a fuck." I don't
give a [__] That is condoning it. That
is condoning it. If you say, "I don't
give a [__] if that happens to this
person," you're condoning it. You're
saying, "I'm fine with it." That's it.
That's condoning it, you [__] [__]
It's so [__] crazy.
He should.
He doesn't. I don't know what I'm meant
to say.
>> It's just like It's not It's not even
just being an idiot, though. It is being
self-interested. That's something that
pisses me off with Becky, is he gets
away with being an idiot.
But, he is being quite self-interested
here. That is what is actually
happening.
It's totally [__] insufferable to
talk to people like this who will act so
[__] obstinate cuz they are self- cuz
they are self-interested,
and because they've got a [__]
audience, they don't see it. They don't
see this person is the most obstinate
[__] alive.
It's so crazy. [__] lying.
[__] I would be so [__] Do you
think he's being dishonest to his
audience?
I don't know. I don't almost need to see
Nick's coverage of the lawsuits
themselves. What did he say when these
What What did he say when these came up
in the lawsuit? Unless I see Nick
literally staring at this exact part of
the lawsuit. I
I cannot possibly determine whether he's
telling the truth or not. Unless I see
Nick literally stare at this part of the
lawsuit and and say, "Oh, yeah. It's all
just members only content." I can't
possibly say he's lying. I can't
possibly say he's lying. You [__]
idiot. You really think this is going to
work, Beckett? You're an idiot. You're
an idiot.
suits. He read them, right?
Because I guess that's the litmus test,
in my opinion.
Yes, Queenan.
Let me picture a hypothetical to you,
Beckett. It's a hypothetical. So, this
is like the classic debate stuff. So,
right.
Milo rapes two women.
Okay, one is 18, one's actually a girl,
one's still a woman, one's 15. Okay?
And you say to me,
"Milo raped a child." And I say, "No,
the rumor is that Milo raped an adult."
And you put her ID in front of my face
and you say, "No, she was 15."
And I say, "No, the the rumor is she was
18." Am I lying?
No, you're certainly sweeping.
You're sweeping. You're not saying
that's lying.
Well, it depends. It's crazy. Okay. And
you say it's not the case.
Okay.
So, you No, no, no. The way you phrase
this is like the way like it's a ru- the
rumor is she's an adult. Like these
aren't the same things. We're not
talking about
>> then? What does Nick say then? Nick says
the rumor was that he was It says here
it's so transparent. Becca is like one
of these people pleasers, man. He's
actually trying to tell me the word that
he thinks will get him out of it without
pissing someone else off. It's
insufferable to deal with, truly.
king. Or he was It was going after
members-only content. Yes. That is the
case in one out of five or seven
instances. Yes. He knows that's That is
a lie, user. We already went over it. If
you pretend to not know something when
you do know it, you are lying. That's
That's you lying. We've already gone
over it many different times.
But nice try. You're not going to get me
distracted more than that. Is that Nick
Hassan is your friend kind of way or
Hutch is your boy kind of way?
Like in a Hutch is your boy kind of way.
Thank you for the don- don't know. He's
an appreciate. Thank you. the claim. He
knows Paige Christie has sent him a
Reddit link that links to all the
evidence. Which he doesn't appear that
he responded to or [__] read.
No, he did respond to it. He did.
>> No, he responded to it with one message
and said, "If it's for Market
Replacement, that's based." And then
Paige sent two more messages. What What
exactly happens here? What What is he
replying to when he says that, Becca?
He's responding to Paige Christie
sending the Reddit link.
Yes. So, he's not So, he's not read it.
He's not read it at the time that he
responded to Paige.
>> no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Listen to what he says in this segment
again, Becca. He says he actually did
look at the Reddit page, but he didn't
believe it because it was on Snark.
Then, what else does he say? He says, "I
was waiting to give my take when the
lawsuits came out." And the lawsuits
were that. What's in the lawsuits,
Becca?
Lawsuit
As we've discussed, it's there's
reference for the DMCA stuff.
>> a list of the DMCA's and yet Nick is
still pretending that he doesn't know
that they're
not members content.
Yeah, sure. And he should focus on that
and be like, "Yes, we should
>> No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No.
No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No.
No. No. No. No. No.
>> I don't want to attribute
>> That was totally natural. No pause. No
pause. No internet drop. Nothing.
Nothing. That was totally legit. That
was literally That was nothing changed
there. That is as it happened. That is
as it happened. [laughter]
How [__] crazy is that?
I just What do you even say, man? What
do you even say?
Let's rewind it back. Let's see it
again. When you do
focus on that and be like, "Yes,
>> No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No.
No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No.
No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No.
It's so good.
I don't want to attribute That That That
That's a yes. That's just a yes. That's
a yes.
Contest a different part. Contest a
different part.
At least accept that to pretend not to
know when you do is to lie.
And then say
I don't think Nick actually knew. But
you can't argue that either cuz it's
such a [__] absurd argument. It's But
you got literally to get stuck on that.
You are so [__] man. Come on.
You've got There's such a thing you have
to be able to concede. You If you can't
concede that
you're not engaging honestly. I'm sorry.
You just aren't. If you cannot concede
that pretending not to know when you do
to ignore wrongdoing is lying
then you just
you need to go back to the drawing board
completely. You're You're not You're not
Clearly you're not engaging honestly or
you've got an emotional block or
something.
But you you need to You need to go back.
You need to just
take it all down, start over.
Figure out what's wrong with you. Cuz
you should not get stuck on that.
There is no no world where you should
get stuck on that question.
That's crazy.
I don't want to attribute to Deal Oreos
that he is lying
>> [laughter]
>> about this. I don't.
>> I know you don't. I know you don't. I
know why you don't as well.
>> No, no. Hold on.
I don't Oh my god. Look, I don't think
it makes that much of a [__]
difference. In the On the other extreme,
he is saying I don't know if I provide
these people with
>> make a difference anymore, Beckett,
because you just I've just worked you
down to a corner and you've lashed
yourself
>> I don't Don't No, I've got like no
>> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I
was like I was like I was like I was
like I was like I was like I was like I
like I was like I was like I'm just I
I'm trying to engage with this as
honestly as possible.
But
What do you mean by that?
Seriously, what do you mean by that?
I want to know.
You're trying to engage with it as
honestly as possible. How about you just
engage with it honestly?
What do you mean by that?
I
And you know this about me.
I treat an accusation like lying is
really serious. I think it is fine to
say that D'Orio is obfuscating the
issue, and he's not focusing on the
arguments Pages making, and he moves on
quickly. Is he lying to his [__]
audience? I don't know. And I actually
have See what he said during his
coverage of the lawsuit. And how he
deals deals with it then. Because if his
position is that he
>> The the lawsuit that he said he was
going to watch last review, and I think
he watched like 5 minutes of it and then
clicked off basically and still still
carried on supporting. Yeah. Yeah. Just
like yeah, you know, the DMCA strikes
are in there, they shouldn't be or like,
you know, whatever [__] the H3
uh H3
should be doing or like
>> in the lawsuit. It's a It's not whether
they should or shouldn't be in the
lawsuit. No. The lawsuit shouldn't be
happening for them. But I'm That's not
That's not even a matter that Nick uh it
matters for Nick to opine on. Why does
it matter whether they should be Because
Because Becca, let me explain to you.
They're just referenced in the lawsuit.
They don't actually form like some
They're not asking for some restitution
according to those
>> But didn't we know about this already?
No, didn't we know already that like
Ethan had gone I feel like this isn't
new information. I feel like there was a
pretty public discussion on all of these
[__] streams.
>> About what?
>> About the fact that Ethan was going
after the H3 snarkers and wanted the
names of the mods and therefore was
utilizing the lawsuit
>> that's been told is that it was members'
content or for reupload reupload mirrors
to siphon views, and that is a lie.
Bro, I thought To be fair, I thought
Ethan was suing them for defamation at
one point.
Okay, well, you've got no idea what's
going on clearly, Becca. That's fine.
I'm telling you Nick, I'm show I'm
literally showing you the evidence right
now that Nick was sent the evidence of
the strikes December 2024 January 2025
page Christy's video releases January
2025 in
the debate what is it May
it's brought up Nick
still pretends not to know then so you
know you could maybe give him benefit of
that say that maybe he didn't look at it
back then or something the lawsuit's
brought out yet so it wasn't confirmed
but then past that debate lawsuit's come
out it's referenced in there it's
absolutely confirmed that the stuff in
that subreddit is absolutely true.
He then reviews the page Christy video
has to be ignorant. That's all I bet it.
Okay.
I would say at the very least he's
misinformed.
I don't like the I don't like using the
word lying but like at the very least
he's off his game. It's fine. At the at
the very least at the very least back it
but then it's a lie back it. He's been
sent the evidence he's acknowledged the
evidence but then
he says in this clip that he's read the
Reddit thread and he just didn't believe
it but then
subsequently then that information
subsequently past when he read I haven't
done any Dennis clips tonight. Now if
you want me to do Dennis clips feel free
to send me Dennis clips. At the very
least back it but then it's a lie.
He's been sent the evidence he's
acknowledged the evidence huge
appreciate thank you. This is number
one. Since he's replied to it he says in
this clip that he's read the Reddit
thread and he just didn't believe it.
Yeah if he was going to respond to this
page Christy stuff subsequently then
that information subsequently Yo thank
you Abby Presley for the five gifted
memberships huge appreciate.
We won't we won't set a hard goal I
can't keep track of it and yeah there's
no incentivization on the screen [__]
but you know guys if just you know
support the stream I'll probably go for
a bit longer with some chat and chat and
dicks and stuff okay we'll do it on a a
gentleman's agreement basis okay.
subsequently past when he read that
Reddit thread had been confirmed 100%
undoubtedly by Ethan side so it was
already confirmed before that by the way
I don't so I there's no yeah we're
playing stupid [__] games here
pretending the lawsuit is when it gets
confirmed but if you want absolutely
nail in the coffin evidence from Ethan's
side to say that he I see you in the 499
super sticker from Jim with 11 lime
character high fiving. Huge appreciate.
What's been said there I just missed it.
Undoubtedly by Ethan's side. So it was
already confirmed before that by the
way.
There's no Yeah, we're playing stupid
[__] games here pretending the
lawsuit is win. It gets confirmed. But
if you want absolutely
nail in the coffin evidence from Ethan's
side Ethan mouth his eyes, [music]
that's where it is.
By that point there is
Thank you for the quality 10 New Zealand
dollars. Huge appreciate. Thanks so
much. Thank you. No excuse.
This video in this video Nick is
pretending otherwise. He is pretending
to not know.
Okay.
Sure.
Go.
So you know I
I'm I'm good. I got my pound of flesh.
You know you
Like some reason say that to actually go
down to the the the [__] bone
defending this. When it's [__] it's
like I mean hold on. When I started this
conversation it was just Beckett won't
call out anything Deorio does. And my
point has been when it's come to the
lawsuits when it's come to any Yo, thank
you for the 50 CZK the news. Huge
appreciate with the Shiba Inu dog
training. Thank you so much on the 10
pounds from weed. Fun for the snark
fairy to stay up a tiny bit longer.
Thank you. Huge appreciate. Thank you.
>> Fun for the snark fairy to stay up a
tiny bit longer.
>> I've got one minute. Beckett like this
annoyed me man. He says that I totally
mean never criticize you. I don't say I
literally did not say that. I did not
say that. I say that he always avoids
the obvious final conclusion. Obvious
final conclusion. Lyle convoys abusive.
Nick Deorio is lying.
At
Deltamoth with the 50 US dollars
with a Shiba Inu dog uh doing a you're
amazing
with some sparklers.
And he's wearing a little samurai
helmet. That's awesome. Now that's just
awesome. It's But to see really. Thank
you for the $50 Dalmoff. Huge
appreciate. Thank you so much. We will
absolutely
be continuing on a bit later with the
content tonight.
So, huge appreciate, guys. Thank you so
much. You do this Ethan Klein stuff.
I've been massively [__] When you
start this conversation if you want to
start this conversation like a year ago.
>> Yeah, yeah, but I didn't say to Yeah,
all I said to Becca is he avoids that
obvious final conclusion that's actually
like condemning or implies malice,
right? He will go He will say, "They did
a thing wrong, but they will never He
will never accept the final conclusion
that reflects on their character."
Thank you for the $2 butterflies with
the smiling shiba inu dog. Thank you so
much. Maybe maybe that's it, but I've
never seen That's so good. That's so
good.
I'm not saying that. I'm saying you will
always find a way to avoid that final
step, the obvious conclusion that
logically follows that is actually
damaging. That is what you avoid. You
will You will go, "Oh, yeah, she done
that. Oh, he [__] that up." You will
do that. You will never say, "lied." You
will never say But I do I Okay.
>> specific Sure. There is There is Okay.
>> application of malice. Okay. Sure. Yes.
And you can see this in my videos. You
can see this in other content I put out.
I'm incredibly [__] charitable. But
you can go and watch my [__] videos.
I treat them so bad, though.
Queenstown. Great
Keep it up. Proud of you.
Sorry, let me check your username so I
can thank you properly. But thank you
for the $30 on Streamlabs. That's huge
appreciate. Thank you so much.
Um
Til- Tiltum Hex, Titum Hex? I'm not sure
how to Tiltum Hex, I think.
Thank you. Hugely appreciate. Thank you.
Thank you.
For the $30.
>> [clears throat]
>> Sorry, I just wanted to go back
slightly. So, "lied." You will never say
>> But I do I Okay.
>> A A specific
>> Sure. There is There is Okay.
>> application of malice. Okay. Sure. Yes.
And you can see this in my videos. You
can see this in other content I put out.
I'm incredibly [__] charitable. But
on, you can go and watch my [__]
videos. I saw I saw
>> [laughter]
>> Dude.
I
don't I don't believe you're actually
this.
You're actually this charitable with
everyone. I think this is about your
friends and it's about your friends.
He's just He's just like
Go and look at my video.
I don't believe him. I don't believe
him. I don't believe anyone's this
charitable to everyone. I don't think
that's the case. I think this is like a
a standard that you're only going to
uphold for your friends.
Right? To be this
forgiving. And usually it's because you
want to maintain the connection. It's
not actually because you feel that way.
It's because you want to maintain the
connection you find yourself in a
problem.
I did this with KP. I did this with Emmy
for the Saberspark stuff.
I I've done this I've done this with
>> sure I've heard you throw throw around
other people lying. You know, you went
pretty hard on Fowlie, too, in the end.
Yeah, well, at that point I had a
[__] ton of evidence and stuff that
had been personally done to me. Like I
didn't just have a couple of
So,
when it comes to Hold on. When it comes
to my big content
>> the Okay, you saying you have tons of
evidence. I feel like the second part
like you said that was a bit more
determinative maybe. And this is my
problem. It all feels very personal when
I talk to you. It feels like No, I just
I just
I did bug
Was it
>> [laughter]
>> When was this made exactly? Who made it?
Was this made by bug? Was this a bug
one? I don't I don't think we ever used
this on stream cuz everything was a bit
hot at that time. You know what I mean?
But
that's just crazy. That goes That goes
crazy.
It's about who your friends are and
that's what seems to ultimately
>> But that's But that's also that's also
not fair, Quinn. You've watched me burn
[__] bridges over the years. You've
watched me not take the side of friends
in like cases where they're fighting
with people. You've watched me call out
people I'm very close to
>> yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah.
>> You've watched me do that. I've done
that.
I I've done that I've done that around
you.
But like yes, I've been I am consistent
on this. Go and watch my [__]
Saberspark video.
I'm like at the end
>> yeah. Just just you know At the end of
the video
>> better than to raise your hand to the
dawn. I understand, Backer.
>> Okay. Okay, well again
I'm at least I'm at least engaging with
you, dude.
Like I'm not trying to like
>> No, no, yeah. I Backer, look. I I you
know, we always I thought we have the
same, you know, aftercare every time,
Backer.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Listen. I I I engage
with people. Yeah, I know yeah, we we
talk, Backer. Yes, I I love that you
talk to me. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. I think
it's I I think the con- I think this is
a I think this is a [__] up Backer
asking for head pats and the
conversation If he was going to cover
the Paige Christie video, he shouldn't
just like move straight off from the
DMs. They're his [__] DMs. He
probably should have dug into it more
and given that like information to his
audience. Probably should have Like
you're saying probably probably should
have probably should have It's It's all
right. He should have. But again
He's deliberately not doing the [__]
He's deliberately not doing it. It's all
right. It's like you're saying, "Oh, you
probably should have done that. You
probably should have done No. No, he's
like deliberate- He's like avoiding
doing that at all [__] costs. That's
like literally the point of the segment
is to pull the video up and not do that.
Okay.
Man.
>> Yeah. I'm going back.
>> Should have done that. Suddenly no one's
>> You good?
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, Backer.
>> Okay. Okay. Cheers, buddy.
All right.
Okay, now.
Okay.
There we go.
Yes.
Ah.
Okay.
So guys, we'll listen to a little bit of
him afterwards. Just see see how you
think he sounds about that conversation.
>> Fine.
We're done, and I've still avoided
watching Keemstar's video on stream.
With this stuff
It's fine.
Once again
I'm more than happy to hear arguments
from other side. I'm unconvinced by the
first clip. Sure, this one with Paige.
The governance the coverage is a [__]
show.
But yeah, okay. Back to Jeremy. I think
we're done with Jeremy. Actually, should
we check in with Jeremy and see if he's
like [__] drunk tweeting still.
Dude, what a [__] [__] show.
What is
So
at some point Zizele comes in and asks
what did Nick do or some [__]
Sargon replies. Oh no, buddy.
Oh, bro.
That's uh
That's not a good sign.
Okay.
Okay. So.
Why does he have not one but two The
Good Place clips on his sidebar? Uh say
for extra trauma.
Why the [__]
are you reposting
Kevin Sorbo?
Dude.
That is actually [__] dire.
That is actually [__] dire, bro.
Try to distract himself.
What a [__] mess.
I wonder I wonder what he's going to do
when he wakes up sober tomorrow.
Ah.
Zizele, what happened? Had an argument
with Kraemer.
Over Nick, you will not be surprised to
hear.
I don't know. what's your read the way
on the way he's talking?
Back at Cool as a
Cool as are in Coolings?
I don't think I take random Coolings. I
literally just cream him.
Oh, okay.
Hope you're enjoying your weekend,
Nitro.
What did Nick do?
Um when the DMCA stuff with Reddit came
out and when Paige when he covered Paige
Christie's video on it.
He deeply obfuscates
certain
aspects of the lawsuit to do with the
Reddit DMCA.
Aidan wants to call in.
I'm not doing it, Aidan. Call in. Aidan
doesn't call in, but you know, it's done
now.
You know.
>> [laughter]
>> He's unhappy, isn't